i add to it
the next sentence but everything of
value i've learned from peter
you
know the rest yes
okay
few pictures i guess
three circles of families
starting with very young peter
somewhat older still very young peter
but in the second circle
and then the cell the circle which is
academic
so david blackwell and eric lemon
and
the younger generation which i just
speak
random number
pictures that i had in the home so it
was simple to put
anyhow
so this is the
background
a
few things about this talk which is too
small probably to read and this is a
problem
and
the subject of the talk would be
statistical testing
it is historical account
so it's not a research paper
historical account of a work done during
60 years from his phd to unpublished
recent paper
the common theme is nonparametric
assumptions at least on those
alternatives
saying history about peter is slightly
understatement because peter is making
history so we have to
think this takes this in mind
i was surprised to the level of
uniformity of that i found in these
papers
the sequence would be chronological but
there is no
almost no order
i want to make a point
that this is not a history of testing
nor it is intellectual history of peter
but a small intersection of the two that
is
peter and testing
which is not a main topic for peter
and
the main in a nutshell
what i see is
this
basic tensions that
we have in i guess peter has
that statistic a testing is
many things
for example in the field that brought
peter to statistics psychology
testing is much more important than
destination slightly more important for
example because what is now is called
transfer learning
so if you do experimental psychology
your issue is transferable ending and
estimation doesn't transfer easily
testing much more easier and therefore
the focus should be on testing because
testing can be generalized
estimation values are not generalized a
function of
the first in students which used to be
these research
sample
in the history of the talks of amazon
currently they are not the general
population
so
making estimation
is not
something that makes any sense moreover
everything is in context of experiment
and nobody cares about this particular
manipulation
we want to generalize and this is
testing
however
we are used to think about optimalities
that is what we are trying to do
optimality minimax efficiency and we
don't have a notion
or the concept of optimality in the
in
testing
final
the talk
would be as i see it in a c minor in
relatively undertoned
i live i guess the d major finale with
crescendo and tutti and all this to the
last talk which probably will be
delivered
okay but i'm supposed to celebrate
so there would be
some music
and then
and
so i try to look on the work of peter on
the 60 years of
work
[Music]
pictures
[Music]
this is the most satisfaction outside
statistics
[Music]
and this is the most satisfaction by you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the young generation
[Music]
[Music]
know
[Music]
okay
there would be more
[Music]
so let's start
with
a
little known paper of peter from 2000
called knowledge and automatic
statistics compared and contrasted
uh
which tries to understand or to make a
point what is nonparametric and what is
not and in particular that the word
nonparametric is used in two orthogonal
ways
in statistics
so there are two layers of two types of
non-parametric statistics one of them is
a
the older version
a
which is dealing with things say
is a same
the what is usually called now
nonparametric statistic i think the one
is the sense of non-parametric
statistics that would be
used the
in the oneness at least one of the
afternoon talks
is something that is connected with
density estimation regression
non-parametric so-called non-parametric
regression
a
the
main point
that this
procedure will developed not so far with
the notions of
of
asymptotics distribution
inference etc
but it bears something like consistency
no confidence
real confidence
bounds and p-values
and the central point is a sentence in
blue
that says for vj
however practically speaking the
technique so many uses explanatory tools
and compared by their visual effects
visual results
these were not peter's words
it means that he sees them for the first
time this
today i'm not sure he saw them before
what
you what
you also read the red sentence
in the right sentence say a sympathetic
approximation were developed but the
criteria of optimality such as
integrated mean square arrow where and
are not driving force
rather the development development of
interesting pretty pictures
for exploratory analysis it's permanent
and the editor didn't agree to publish
this sentence
so
this sentence was supposed to be change
and it was changed to the blue what what
journal was that
a
statistical uh what is this
[Music]
didn't um officially because
i don't believe that there was a referee
in the middle
but
the compromise was the blue one but
peter has had nothing to do with this
compromise
the older sense of nonparametric
statistics is
things like
a
rank test
things well you want to guarantee p
values for non-parametric policies
and then
the
driving force of all this work was
classical inference say
p-value testing
here you have the notion of a robustness
which is part of this package
part of this trend of nonparametric
statistics in the infrastructure of the
world no pretty pictures
a semi-parametric
is a sort of
line to
local nonpro sort of nonparametric
problems but with info strongly with
emphasis on influence
sql to end rate optimality
bootstrap would appeal which is the main
topic of peter
is a combination of
this concept of non-parametric it's
getting started with non-parametric
maximum likelihood estimator
with the idea of being able to plug in
and
it is strongly related to a permutation
test of course
and
the only
idea is to
influence
okay
so we have to continue with music
and
[Music]
so again trying to figure out
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
that's it
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
thanks to the university for a michigan
marching band
okay
the early stage local alternative this
is the phd thesis or the paper a paper
based on the disease
and some synthetically in automatic
competitors of the hotel links d square
so i'll be
very fast i'll
ten years ago there was i think it was a
talk by project
in berkeley
the international congress of
mathematicians
but it was one of the russians and the
talk was given in a
russian with the interpret interpreter
and then peter described it is that the
second slide was wrong with a lot of
details
the speaker
talked about it 10 minutes
and then the translator said
assumes it is prohibited mr pojorov
presented something that we all know so
we can move on
and that was the last slide that could
follow
so
a
so the paper starts with basically a
translation a model multivariate
translation model
you have
an estimator of data
x is vector in lp
delta is the location vector
um
it is based on
basically vectorizing
a
real
univ real estimators invariant
estimators
so you have a
base typically the start structure is
something
like
something like h of the translation
which is mu n
let's say zero but not necessarily
and then
which is the expectation and you try to
equate it
synthotics is based that everything is
the
under local alternative is
a gaussian shift which is proportional
to
the alternative so we are looking on
local alternatives which is the basic
notion of called this work which is
delta n
now it's vector is one over square root
of n a
and
and we have both of the estimator two
types of
synthetics which are strongly related
one of them the distribution of age
under the alternative
this
estimate to this estimating equation so
this is estimating equation
its behavior or the estimator
both of them are normal with shift
and we have two types of
tests which are strongly related one of
them is based on the estimator and one
of them on the estimated equation
and the test are as can be expected
so
everything is derived there is example
we are speaking about the 60 so
the means the wilcoxon name based on
wikipedia
test the median
and then we come to efficiency
because we are dealing with mathematical
statistics
so there is a notion of a pitman
efficiency which was a paramount in the
work of testing
of fetal in the early area
which say that
you compare
the sample size needed to get
to achieve the same asymptotics
and
we get a sort of results like that we
have and the point is that the left hand
side and the right hand side are
typically different
and
so everything is analyzed
and
the conclusion is
the following
and then there are two conclusions
the first is technical
workshone and the medium based tests are
more robust than something that is based
on the media
but
to my talk more important is a
undeveloped statement
and say i'm developed because that's all
is written about it
section 4 also points out to the need of
satisfaction satisfactory criteria on
what is meant by better independent of
delta
a
what is mean by better what is the
better statistics
the problem is that better statistics
depends on the alternatives and there
are a lot of stuff and that's the main
problem of testing
that
the best statistics is depending what
you think about the alternatives and
this is
wild
forest and therefore we don't have
a satisfactory notion of a
in statistics there is another sentence
in the middle
let's say there always exists a
direction in which one does more than in
one dimension whatever estimate one
chooses
and
necessarily because we compare two
things one in which one does better so
directions are
the best statistics depend on the
direction and you don't don't know the
direction
not not much later than that we have an
implication and this is sort of typical
it is well done with a shell
a
test for monotone failure rate based on
normalized spacing
so the model is
that we have a distribution with failure
weight
and
edge notes say
f is exponential
so it's very very much parametric
and h1 is
the failure rate is
how i don't know
and that's again the main problem
the alternative is
not parametric completely non-but almost
completely non-parametric yeah it's not
dramatic even not semi-problematic
well they started with a
set of tests based on other statistics
which are just x-axis locals are
different normalize
them properly
and if it's exponential
this would be iid
so we look on the rank of them
the rank of the
spacings
and
under age note
the spacings are
exponential
and
and under h1 there also causes three
monotone decreasing
and therefore it makes sense to look on
tests which are
in some sense monotone in the spacing
and
the
result of the paper says that all
monotone tests are rank test
if we want to be pure monotone that we
have to do rank test
all monotone tests are on bias that
expected
then
one type of
a
monotone test is one that look on the
rankings something implies some function
of it
weight it
and in particular
the motivation of the paper seems to be
a test suggest suggested
by
say so it's sum of the i r i
and
they say two things about it the first
thing
is it is
not efficient and here we can say
because it's dominated by another test
which is always better
and here is a
again i'm not going to enter into all
the detail to leave enough time for
music
and uh
and the is that then they try to analyze
and what they claim that any test
of this sort
if x is exponential with mean one or
with known lambda it doesn't matter
because we can always say normalize
then the efficiency all tests of this
form are non-efficient
so that's the fact that this sort of
non-interesting results so it's very
strong results that they were able to
prove because if you look on
alternatives
for any alternative any direction you
always can improve it
but if you drop the assumption that you
know the scale
then
suddenly all the standard the
type of
test in particular
the one with the optimal c and j
are
efficient relative to other
tests but still if you know you think
about every test would be efficient
relative to a specific alternative
so this is a
paper
second part of the paper now also by
peter alone
say
the classes are
only
all the statistics of this form
when you have to normalize because you
don't know the scale
or linear function of the spacing
locally most powerful
this based on
the ranks or in particular
way on the ranks
all of them are
asymptotically
to the most powerful test for a given
direction
the problem is that you have to know the
key
similar
problem isn't the following day
shortly there after no it's more than
one year it's 10 years
it's looking on taking
the
work
and so just a test for
how well the model fits a
fits
the assumption which is
uniform and
variance and non-linearity i'll talk
only on the variance part of the story
and
so it is a basic linear model
the
model that we consider
that the variance depend on the expected
value conditional expectation so tau is
the conditional expectation of y given x
the linear part of it
and we consider
local alternatives
that is
h naught is it sigma is one
but it may departure proportional to
theta in a direction a
for example
sigma can be e to the power of a theta
tau
which is
uh some the mo the
deviation
idea
this model there was an estimator there
was a test
and that was proven under condition
somewhat difficult to make precise
if
which is very polite way i would
probably put it in a stronger
statement
and
so a test was suggested
and
we get our test statistics
so the first part of the paper is taking
this test suggested test and making the
condition precise and the proof
pulls real
and then we move to generalize this guy
but now we need complicated conditions
and we need long proofs
and the resulting tests are asking
particular bias
the power is independent of the method
of estimating the parameters which is
again some things that would appear
again and again
there is
explicit theorem for the efficiency or
the relative efficiency of the test
we can choose b
to make things say
in
robust
but if we
zero distribution is known as expected
it be the functions that appear here
is explicit
and
now we are left
what is a
different areas would give us different
tests
which would be
giving me and we don't know hey
that's the whole idea of
our problem with testing that we don't
know the alternatives we have
non-parametric alternatives and a
different alternative would give us a
different test
okay
hey one thing about the graphics all the
graphic except one was done by me
i use the google scroller
except for one tiny point point which is
the name for a ride tobias then which
was the chaotic completely and it
covered the of the screen i didn't touch
anything that is everything is
automatically and it was i know few
points that i would correct if i want
but i insisted of just taking the
automatic results
not to enter into biases
okay
so
one thing that the annoying pito i think
it was very important to film those
courses
so this is the list of the courses
people walk with it and do you imagine
how long it is
how many courses
give me a number
how many numbers would it be
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
cincinnati pops with japanese 105
millimeter railguns
military guns
the ones that you have here
after a touchdown
a
only directional test
okay
so
i mean looking down for 2000 paper by
alice salia
peter and thomas stockel
goodness of feed test for kernel
regression with implications to
option implied volatilities
they care about the options part
counterfeit but the rest yes
so the issue is completely
non-parametric with w
now p v n l q
y
real
and we look on the
nonparametric expectation of y given w
in v
and the age note is that expectation of
y
doesn't depend on v
so
the idea of the paper
is
integrally very simple
let's look on
the non-parametric kernel estimator of
the two expectations
the one expectation of y given the w and
v
and the one and the other
the other one is given only w with the
age note that says that
the two are equal
h1 that they are not equal
so we look on kernel estimators
we are looking in high dimension canon
estimators in high dimension is
catastrophic here it is small because we
look
we have to compare a test
it's really nasty job
the assumptions are
nasty
the kernel should have r
which is larger than three p plus huge
all the dimensions we are talking about
three-quarter of the sum of the
dimension
zero moments so it's non-standard
estimator we have to keep the bias
that's the big problem
everything we try to look on the numbers
okay it's not common
in the worst case scenario
but
under the result is it underage node the
test statistic is asymptotically normal
with a given to complement it for me
meaning violence but it appears in the
paper
so the next stage of the paper that i
saved myself the trouble of looking is a
complicated estimator of the two
complicated meaning variance
which will return to it but now we are
looking
again
our story looking under alternatives
that's the main idea
and
the test is not trivial power
if
epsilon
is
very large
because you have h here
you think you probably are
larger than one and therefore it's very
slow
so that's what i said
you want to be
omnidirectional
the price for being unidirectional is
not you are not omnipotent you are
impotent
you don't have power in any direction
and that is the main conclusion we will
return to this model in the last slide i
guess talk
okay
so if we are talking about
and
so now another look on the castles
because
[Music]
oh that's the network
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]
okay
and we are coming to the
bootstrap
and i'll not explain that right
okay
as we said the bootstrap is a plug-in
estimator
you want to estimate parameters the
distribution of the statistics tn under
the null
under the two distribution
and you consider the distribution of tn
under
the empirical distribution or
any other estimator but
the standard boots up what people
usually understand visiting bootstrap is
under the empirical
it works when the law of the given the
two distribution is continuous in its
some neighborhood of a
n
which is consistent with the empirical
the empirical is close to the two enough
to have this continuity of the
distribution and therefore the
distribution of the under f can be
estimated by plug plugging in
z empirical
the m out of n and bootstrap was the
short
already in the first paper of people a
beacon in friedman which is almost i
guess the first real paper about
so we not the ones that surrendered they
would stop but
the ones that analyze it
and
it was mentioned then because problem
with situation where
fm
doesn't belong to this neighborhood this
is relevant it's it's not close enough
to
the truth
for having this continuity
but
only we need to have much more precise
estimate also i
played it between the two
so
usually you look at it in the opposite
direction
f n belong
to the relevant
neighborhood
under
a sample of size n
as an example there was a typical
example is the maximum of the uniform
distribution
and the problem there is that there are
anomalies because of ties for example so
we know that the
asymptotic distribution of
the maximum is
after normalization
exponential
continues
but if we do bootstrap it will be
very discrete
okay this is when we usually talk about
sort of confidence interval
the story in testing is completely
different
because in any or almost non-trivial
case almost all non-trivial cases fn
is not
doesn't belong to h naught
we want to know the estimate is the
behavior of the estimator under h naught
and the empirical doesn't belong to z
so
i could take many papers that are
dealing with this this is a huge topic
in a
ptlc portfolio i picked one of them
and
the main idea is that we have a
we have
some statistics that they can tell us
we have to look on the distribution
under
m smaller than n
and if we have the standard asymptotic
the square root of n asymptotics
and we center properly everything will
work
i not enter into the details as
the translator said we all know it
we all know them
so we cannot we don't have to mention it
eh
and they under a
few particular trivial
very general structures that the reason
it's really check of all trades
the aim out of n
test work with true power function and
continuous interval
so it gives you
what we want
it is
so something is missing in this
description because
if we assume that everything is a square
to form standard square of any
asymptotic say why do we need a
bootstrap at all well
where is a
problem
and uh there is another paper that i
want to mention by my two advisors now
peter and you see i have
um
any
this is under the situation where what
we try to estimate we assume that there
is
a sort of expansion
and now
we can look on
the aim out of any bootstrap but under
different aims
and we can
find the
extrapolate
to get the distribution under n
the main focus of the paper is different
is they doing in an optimal way because
it saves a computation
i didn't mention just because we are
speaking about a statistic in the big
era
in his first paper he writes that's the
one the problem with the whole jason
lemon
estimator
is that
the computation is the level of n square
log n which is
almost impossible
you wrote it
yeah and
okay
so that's the basic idea and we are
coming
to the final trip oh not the final
chapters the current chapter sorry sorry
sorry the current chapter
and then this is a
archive paper
correlation with stellar external
properties
so it started by a work of
12
they try to find a
non-parametric
test
for a
[Music]
distribution we have x y and we want
to basically
test whether x and y are independent
so the test is based on text access all
of them
uh ranks the
y's
rank them give our eye to the ranks of
the y
to be the length of the y i
if the x and y are independent of course
they are all
independent
uh
if
they are not
then if r i is large
we expect
i plus one which is
the next the close to it would be close
to it the next y then like
of the following x would be
almost as large
and therefore we expect this to be
in
to be a test
so cn uh
is converting to cxi which was suggested
by that a
in fact
and c
has property that is it is between 0 and
1
c 0 only if x is orthogonal
to y independent of y
it is 1 if y is the precise function of
a
of a x
c is asymmetric in y and x so c x y is
not c y of x
let's hear
copy and paste the g should be
let's say sort of ignore this line
it is strongly related to the classical
symmetric
maximal correlation of the knee which is
symmetric which look on the
super moment over all g and h of the
correlation between function of x and
function of y
r square is a maxima eigenvalue of the
self-rejoined operator of conditional
expectation given y conditional
expectation given x or vice versa
and
it's a metric it's nice it has some
abnormalities that is uh you can make r
go to 1 while c go to zero because just
we pick a point from then
so it's not
much better
it's more
there are
reason to prefer one on the other but
that's theoretical
um
took me time to read what they wrote
the problem is
that it is a hebrew the first time you
will be a little faster
and
if you subsides a lot you have no size
at all
i guess
the
efficiency of this model would be zero
under nd
under any contiguous alternative
that's the same problem as we saw in the
econometrics paypal
when you try to be omnidirectional you
get zero efficiency for any direction
so what can be
done
older paper of peter from 2006
taylor made tests for goodness feeds in
semi-perpendicular hypothesis which
dealt with
is basically
a with a
same
problem with
saying
almost same
conclusions
and look on basically look on
the model
we have here we look on the parametric
model so we look on all classes
parametric model like set
which under
the null theta equals zero would give us
independence
we
create a
some correlation between the two but we
permit
basically we look on the
capillar
but so we don't know the transformation
of say x and the formation of y
we can create the tangent spaces for
letter one theta two et cetera do the
projection and eventually we get the
projection is
all function of a of x and y
which has mean zero conditional
expectation
under the conditional expectation under
x zero equation expectation under y
equals zero so we just take any function
and we have to normalize it it's
comparable so it's under the uniform
it's relatively simple
and we get
for any particular test we get the log
likelihood standard test so we get this
expression
so we now can combine them and this
is the all
this is zero
in expectation
on only under the knife all of them
would be zero only on those enough
so each one of whatever is the two
alternative
it would have some power
one of them would have some power now we
sum them because otherwise because we
have infinite of them so we have to
temper them that's the title if you
remember the title
the white temple
[Music]
jack of all
trades so that's the tempering
and the
we get a test we can do this like that
we can do it like a common goal smear
nose look on the maximum whatever
i don't say that this is and we don't
say this this is the only way
to combine them together but the basic
idea was and this isn't the last as i
said the last the paper of the topic of
peter this last paper on the topic of
peter that i know about a
is the idea of how you can combine tests
and get something which is
which has power against all alternatives
and more power against the more
interesting alternatives and you have to
decide what is more interesting
okay
and
to finish the celebration
okay so i i
i took two purchase
uh
to the least of all also i now want to
what i think should be the right
my point of view
[Music]
days of our lives
[Music]
big four is with real for all sorts of
individuals
okay thank you
so i have a question yes
what is the role of testing in the big
data era when you have millions of
observations and thousands
okay
first of all
my little experience
is that you never have
hello
you never have it
you always have very weak terrible
because if you have
a lot
big not a large number of data points
two questions are
becoming precise
you don't collect
millions of data points
to ask questions which are you can
answer by 100.
so
my personal experience to give you a new
field i had
all
called to a call center of middle
science american bank
for half
the problem is that all data to all
calls for medium size the north eastern
bank melbourne bank
weren't enough to answer the precise
question which is what happened 10
o'clock in the morning for the typical
so the same questions
exist
now
my main
name point as i said is
why testing is important because it is
the same testing
and if i'm looking from
this surrounding where we collect
experiments
experiments are
experimental we want to move and this is
again the same problem with medical
all this issue of transfer learning
your sample population is not the
general population then
it's very
uh meaningless to ask about estimating
parameters because the parameters are
not going to generalize
question whether something works or not
you may hope
[Music]
[Music]
in which directions i'm good
try
to combine them
the two people that i mentioned
two last three slides
combining set of
[Music]
because as much as i
could see you don't care about things
like you don't care about the taste the
test is giving for you you try to see
how you can end it
you don't come with this you don't
suggest this
so there's a procedure to
i think this is a discussion we can
continue outside we'll stay in 15
minutes and thank you for having